you know that when researchers from
Harvard looked at people who had made a
major change in their lives in a
positive way okay so you take a group of
people that made a major change in their
life half of those people the reason why
that change happened is because
something either traumatic or something
that was a major life event happened
they got cancer they lost somebody they
loved they got a divorce they suddenly
were laid off they lost all their money
like something happened that was a major
life event that rocked them and you know
what happens when that happens to you
first it's horrendous but it usually
leads to something very positive
happening now the other half of the
people who had made a very positive
change in their life do you want to know
what they did what they did is they
changed their friends they started
surrounding themselves with people that
were up to the same thing that they
wanted to be doing